[Musique]
déjà pour la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux belle
cette issue le plus sérieux
kasami n'invite pas jouer contre lui il
suffit de vouloir revenir à camille
on va commencer tout de suite cette
chanson oui parce que dis je un peu là
terminaux au nom on recommence pour nous
mon nom mais bon au nom on l'a bien fait
là et moi au wi fi après tu sais ce qui
se passe quand tu chantes trop longtemps
eh bien tu n'as plus de voir un jet de
jean-marc il a un prêche hybride comme
tu veux un jeux géographiques et aux
goûts
t'as pas envie de travailler non enfin
le jeu le pays
oui le pays allez hop le pays allez hop
là je me redresse la carte du pays le
drapeau du pays et bonjour dans la
langue du pays
et cette fois-ci tout encore c'est toi
qui vas chercher si tu veux et je ne
dirai rien d'une dation regarde tout
d'abord la carte du pays
la voile à bord bon ensuite la capitale
et titien bien je te montre drapeau du
pays
ah ça c'est un drapeau rouge avec
une étoile et un croissant blanc non non
c'est pas le même
et puis la prononciation ne sera pas
garantie
dans la langue de ce pays on dit qu'une
aydin je ne sais bonjour c'est bonjour
grenadine de nadine que nadal je suis
pas là je ne pourrais pas t'aider et je
fais ce que je peux vous avez dû n'être
qu'une halle d'après toi quel est ce
pays alors c'est peut-être le pire ou
non ce n'est pas le pire ce pôle pérou
en garde qui regarde regarde la carte
avec ça c'est bordé de
et passez bordée de quoi jacques demers
il ya deux mers tu donnes ta langue au
chat
oui non se veut te le dire ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est ce que j'ai comme ça
oui c'est turc
oui parfaitement fort mais oui il s'agit
de la turquie et les usa team a mis sur
la voie non d'une aydin et oui on tu
penses c'est un pays qui est à cheval
sur deux continents
parce que tu vois ici c'est l'europe et
puis ici c'est nazi
et là c'est la capitale ankara car voilà
le drapeau et bonjour en turc cuneyt
dean
voilà une affaire qui a été vite rider
l'aiguillé vivement mener 28 ans est pas
mal sorti je suis content bon tu vas où
moi je m'en vais je t'ai pas dit de
sortir je m'en vais quand même foi de
ces logements va mal les cas seuls bons
candidats et les partis tous et puis on
a mis tout de suite je vais vous dire
pour le point commun est celui là oui
alors là je le connais bien sûr ah bon
étudier pour mathieu qui cela est fait
des bonds s'appelle fabrice fabrice
abriel oui oui c'est à quel sujet où
vous n'avez pas piquant cote avec vous
j'ai vous demande pardon et j'espère au
tissu de vous je regarde ça va gelly
chapeau j'apporte la leur un hic
on n'y arrivera pas un cil et restent
au-dessus 1 messieurs riche il écrit
mais consent à la la la la la la
structure il m'énerve mais le vois comme
alors le point commun j'ai pas besoin
d'expliquer un an maintenant c'est
comment je peux alors je commence
aujourd'hui je suis un accident mais
attendent attention à pas un accident
d'automobile non un accident de terrain
par accident géographique si vous aimez
mieux tu sais fab risques suivants qu'on
se trouve dans une vallée ou sur des
hauteurs au bord de la mer ou au milieu
d'un désir
les terrains ont des aspects différents
c'est alors voilà adam moi je suis un de
ses aspects je suis
un aspect assez moyen pas trop pas trop
bas tu vois je possède de la végétation
mais pas énormément de l'élevage aussi
or les moutons bêlent madore et on me
trouve en france et puis je lui donne
accès facile faut pas être un montagnard
chevronné pour monter jusqu'à moi c'est
ce que je peux dire très bien - oui
fabrice je suis un théâtre ça me va bien
nous bah oui ça doit bien oui attention
je ne suis pas une comédienne je fais
partie d'un théâtre j'en suis même la
partie essentielle celle sur laquelle
j'ai obtenu mes plus grands succès la
partie qui résonnent des tirades des
grands comédiens
attention ce n'est pas la partie la plus
grande d'un théâtre le même parfois très
exigu mais c'est la partie la plus
vivante il se passe des choses avant que
le rideau ne se lève on sent que c'est
là que le mystère se prépare on y entend
quelques pas attention le silence et
trois coups et cette partie du théâtre
que j'ai suivi va commencer à lui libre
des mondiaux tout ça c'est sûr c'était
là qu'il est très bien joué
oui mais je ne suis un petit peu perdu
là j'aimerais que pousse moussu me donne
sa version de ce qu'il est bien et bien
moi aujourd'hui je suis pour l'égalité
je ne veux pas que quelqu'un soit
avantagé par rapport à quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pour ça que généralement je ne
suis pas tout seul nous travaillons à 2
nous sommes tous les deux exactement
pareil
en général on se met l'un à gauche
l'autre à droite et si on est quelque
chose sur celui de gauche
il faut mettre la même chose sur celui
de droite enfin quand je dis la même
chose je veux dire quelque chose qui
pèse le même poids parce que il ne faut
jamais que je sois plus haut ou plus bas
que mon petit camarade de travail
j'espère que je suis claire oui à brice
oui tu éclaires et c'est grâce à toi
parce que j'ai trouvé et ben je suis
bien content parce que j'étais bien
embêté dès le départ alors je pense que
tout kankan est un simple plateau sur
une montagne c'est un plateau nu
oui il s'agissait pour bell bell du
plateau la scène nous plaît son soutien
à la salle des halles plates ou qu'on
appelle plateau et pour pouces moussu
lui les deux plateaux de la balance
voilà la justice les deux plateaux et
pour leur dire tu trouves et j'espère
que tu trouveras aussi tout à l'heure le
petit jus des notes musicales
en dix ans le général je me débrouille
pas trop mal ah oui et lycées 8 pouces
mais aussi aux nouveaux cas alors comme
suspect oui c'est à nous deux c'est à
nous de laisser notre petit jeu comme
chaque semaine alors à bon nombre assez
pour encore alors on y va on y va
j'espère que tu as ton petit crayon
saiem taille est là la main on joue à
lèvres ah bah oui tu vas au tableau
comme d'habitude tués sans pitié rare
c'est notre jeu c'est notre jeu à nous
le plus difficile c'est d'arriver à
retrouver les mots avec toutes les
fautes d'orthographe que tu mènes nommé
dollars
cette fois-ci il n'a pas de podor pays
je n'ai pas des clubs ont alors fait un
peu pourquoi avec toi pourquoi really
rodez même partant de là il dîne c'est
que c'est parce qu'on est en droit de
dire des mots que témoin peut-être
secondes vas-y bon alors c'est à nous
alors c'est un mot en neuf lettres 9 let
première levée alors la première lettre
c'est un pea
1 2 3 4 5 6 et 7 dernières lettres
dernier relais un i ll oui tiens c'est
bizarre quand est ce que ça peut bien
acétate l'a deviné alors une fleur non
non c'est pas une fleur un arbre c'est
pas un arnaud paix à l'animal c'est quoi
un animal hewitt a trouvé encore un
animal
non il est moyen qu'est-ce qu'il ya tout
cas encore est un animal un animal un
animal qui rend pas au nom non 1 et
baltique ou non pluie court pas encore
partie vol et vol et vol ni vol voilà
dix vols et c'est un oiseau et c'est un
oiseau fine déduction voilà qu'est ce
que cet oiseau lan oiseaux de nos
régions oh oui oh oui oh oui au fait est
ce que tu veux que je donne à la
troisième dette par hasard comme ça pour
t d un peu je veux bien la 3e net c'est
un air et oui de nos régions tu dis à
nos régions bien sûr cran c'est pourtant
facile avec un y à la fin oui j'ai enfin
je je crois est ce qu'il a un bec très
pointu truies oui oui est ce qu'il
répète tout ce qu'on dit par hasard tu
mens tu as trouvé y répète tout ce qu'on
dit ah bon parce que tu pensais sans
doute à perroquets et à perroquet bien
sûr que tu as trouvé enfin penser
aujourd'hui à perroquet naoui la pop et
rock avec un nid à la fin c'est pas
comme ça pe 2 r oui au cul à un nom
quand je dis non c'est pas le quai d'une
rivière
c'est qu eux et un ter à la fin alors et
en ce qui concerne les oiseaux de nos
régions je suis pas absolument persuadé
que le perroquet soit un oiseau de notre
région abba pourtant pas pourtant
pourtant j'en ai vu beaucoup maintenant
on en voit serait chez d'état de journée
arrive pas du tout certain animal c'est
pas de ma faute grave vérifier a tancé
par maman pouces moussu bon d'accord
d'accord mais ce que je peux peut-être
apprendre sur les perroquets c'est que
ce sont des oiseaux qui peuvent se
servir de leurs pattes pour porter leur
nourriture à leur bouche voilà enfin je
veux dire alors bec paribas we are en
sommet ils mangent avec leurs doigts
quoi comme moi je peux moi si je peux
pousser ses des bourgeoises of the cloud
ah oui il a raison
s'allumant et des couleurs aussi p
internet et je trouve que bell bell est
super beau s'y est pas belle bête un
belle bella nom du vivat j'arrive ici et
le map afin que dit alain tu veux tu es
comme un petit qu'elle a jeté un petit
col oui un petit calibre
c'est parce que j'aurai besoin de toi
ces jours ci à je me disais bien aussi
oui si tu pouvais venir passer quelques
instants à la maison bien sûr ça me
ferait plaisir mais tu mets devrait
arranger ma bibliothèque il ya une vague
haye
je voudrais que classe et tout ça j'ai
beaucoup de livres tu sais ils sont bons
certains ont des rouges et des lettres
il faut que tu trouves des notes de
musique qui remplace les coupons
alors allons allons allons allons il est
rond non ça ne peut pas jouir myopie
temps où l'attend une seconde c'est sûr
c'est pas compris ce que match la belle
j'ai fait des cultures sur mes livres
qui ont des belles rouges il ya des
jolies lettres dorées walhalla l'eau il
est qu'ils sont c'est pas ça atteint 2
secondes parce que non et non
donc c'est ça c'est ça mais tu sais bien
où les places c'est quand même
d'habitude tu sais que j'ai des livres
de gilbert par exemple straubing obama
michel strogoff c'est sammy et puis 20
points lieues sous les mers à temps
parce que je suis en retard là va pas
trop vite
voilà vingt mille lieues sous même si ce
sont des réponses passionnant mais quoi
des rythmes passionnant à des récits
lirez ci devant partition non qui
plaisent surtout garçons mais que j'ai
lu avec beaucoup d'intérêt d'un thé
d'intérêt voilà et je possède aussi des
livres plus facile j'ai toutes les
aventures de tintin et milou
oh c'est tintin et milou oublier non le
mis ses pas la piquant boonmee c'est ici
qu'il est juif tu connais aussi le
professeur tournesol un professeur
tournesol et dans les fables de la
fontaine tu connais le louis new et
l'agneau caméra le renard et la gagne
haut la cigogne oui et la gale et l'ap
four la cigale et la fourmi
voilà il y en a tellement tu sais j'ai
dû perdre livre j'ai su noyer
il faudrait que tu viennes bébé est ce
que je peux compter sur toi
le jardin oui mais j'aurais voulu que tu
me fasses encore un petit qu'à l'avant
prochain mais quelles exigences
syndicales visite parisien du chalet
voilà alors viens chanter avec moi
[Musique]
les quatre amis sont déjà sont pas les
amis les câlins ou d'héroïne secret de
la vie majel s'est désisté et rzeszow
fait des choses mais comme juni va demi
noir niveau à faire attention les caps
samy 3d sont réunis mais cap ça mais
sont heureux car il est lié
oui
mon profil
[Musique]
david pas joué aujourd'hui
il s'y voit venir à jamie hince fille de
vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]
manger